so i'm going to start off with a dirty
little secret about textbook publishing
and about religion in america as sort of
a class and a discipline
you always have to attack a textbook
chapter
usually towards the end
sort of like your junk drawer
where you guys know what a junk drawer
is
you know you have everything nicely
organized you know if you're in the
garage you know your wrenches go over
here the screwdrivers go over here and
the nuts and bolts are here really fancy
they're in like you know special
containers where you can see them or
you've got your you know plastic stuff
to contain them maybe tackle boxes
but then you've always got like some
some
box where you got to put all the other
stuff that doesn't fit into the other
categories
we call that a junk drawer or a
miscellaneous category
you know when you're doing a budget
that's your miscellaneous part
always when you're doing a budget have a
miscellaneous thing because that's where
you put the other money that you want to
have and you want to use but you're not
quite sure what you're going to do with
it yet
you know
um life in life we need junk drawers and
miscellaneous accounts because not
everything fits into
some sort of grand scheme all the time
this chapter is kind of like that
we do have a
category that we use
called popular religion
meaning the sort of expression of
religious sentiment or beliefs or
artifacts or things like that that's not
directly tied to some sort of
institutional religion but could reflect
it for example one example of a popular
religion how many of you have been to a
funeral during your lifetime
about everybody okay so what are what
are religious aspects of funerals
that are pretty similar
and it doesn't really matter whether
it's a catholic funeral or protestant
funeral or a jewish funeral
um
or you know an atheist funeral
what are some of the things that are
kind of similar flowers
oh yeah yeah everybody brings flowers
and
um what usually there's quite a few of
them right
sometimes they actually like donate them
to places afterwards uh the caskets like
on the altar
yeah we have these
sometimes called the viewing or
visitation or awake
and you know we embalm the dead person
and you know actually if you look at our
funeral practices and you look at it
from the outside they look really weird
you know
if you're an anthropologist from some
other culture these americans
what are they up to
we have the person the dead person their
body
embalmed if if they're they look nice
enough the casket is open
uh
what else can you say about about that
aspect of it yeah it's like um
the whole like idea i guess would be to
celebrate the person's life not to mourn
never hopefully
some people it's hard like that's not
like it doesn't matter which religion i
guess it kind of that's the idea
yeah some people are harder to do that
with them than others because
if you were a nice guy or not but yeah
they say don't speak ill of the dead you
know
there was a particular color you should
wear to a funeral depending on your
culture maybe black or white
yeah
white would be for some of the asian
cultures you know uh chinese you know
white is associated with with
that um yeah you don't wear your uh your
seersucker suit
to uh to a funeral
or the thing that you're gonna wear to
the
you know
you don't go in and just
you know a heavy metal man t-shirt or
something
um
you wear a nice you know actually for
for men this is good advice that i got
from my mentor you only need to have one
suit if if
you're not a suit wearing guy it's a
black suit because a black suit you can
wear to just about any important
occasion
and you'll probably have occasion to
wear it too to funerals
especially if you're a pallbearer what
are these pallbearers doing isn't that a
weird thing too
you know they're like walking the
the casket around
i mean we have all these things
surrounding
uh
how we deal with death
and they may have had originally
religious significance and we still feel
like they have kind of religious
significance but even if somebody isn't
religious
there's still that aura with it isn't
there
if it's a catholic funeral uh even a lot
of protestant funerals these days you
get prayer cards
because you know it's got the person's
name on it the date
usually like an image of the saints or
somebody like that from from the church
or the funeral home
um another example of popular religion
that they they discuss is a fictional
one that
you guys again probably could relate to
a bit
because it's had a comeback
uh the chapter begins by talking about
uh star wars
and i don't mean people like for whom
star wars is a religion because they get
into the expanded universe and and all
the shows and stuff like that people are
going to be really upset now that
turns out that episodes seven
eight and nine which they're making are
not going to be compatible with the
expanded universe oh it's big big
shocker
people are very angry about this sort of
thing you know
um star wars geeks are
not happy
who are the religious people in the star
wars universe
yeah like jedi and said the jedis well i
suppose the sith it could be kind of a
religion it's a weird
religion because you only have two of
them at any given time right
whereas the jedi there could be a whole
bunch of them that was that was one plot
thing that never made sense to me there
can only be one sith lord and one
apprentice
you know
we don't have a whole bunch of them you
know wouldn't it i mean shouldn't evil
be as tough as the good guys
um
yeah you're right there's a there's a
succession relation
uh
but the jedi are framed like a religion
and some people you know
have gotten so into it that they treat
it as
a kind of religion we just actually
celebrated a kind of secular holiday
uh
what's the day the sixth
so it was two days ago
what was it
may the fourth be with you yeah i mean
you know
silly stuff like that but some people
have a reverence towards this
that's
quasi-religious that those are examples
of popular religion
um
so
some of the things that we're going to
look at fit into that spectrum other
things really don't
um
civil religion is kind of like popular
religion
but civil religion makes the state or
the nation
into the religious object so
i actually got into an interesting
discussion on facebook today
with a conservative friend of mine
who i said i'm too traditional to be
conservative
on this issue and it was about these
people
um who wanted to have american flags on
on cinco de mayo and there was a big you
know tiff back and forth about mexican
flags and american flags and are you you
know oppressing people by putting
american flags there and they were like
guys who painted american flags on their
on their belly and you could tell that
it was like you know supposed to be
inclusive because they had you know some
white guys and some black guys and they
were all doing this this thing
and
i saw this and i was like you know i was
raised
with the flag code and the flag code
says the flag is not supposed to be used
on anything other than flags
not trucks
not bumper stickers not t-shirts not
handkerchiefs it actually mentions
handkerchiefs in the flag code and says
you're not you're not supposed to do
that
um
shortly after 9 11 there were everybody
put flags everywhere and everyone put
flags on everything and go around the
flag t-shirt and you know you're showing
your patriotism
well so yeah here i'd be sort of like
you know the old you know stick in the
mud like martin luther or somebody like
that
if you really respect the flag
that means that you don't put it on
everything
and does anybody get in here know how
you're supposed to dispose of the flag
if it's gotten messed up
you're supposed to burn it yeah now of
course the people who want to burn the
american flag they're they're not
usually like saying well the flag code
xyz they don't want to show that they
don't like
the united states but there's actually
nothing intrinsically wrong with flag
burning the flag code which describes
the sort of
reverence that's part of civil religion
towards the plaque requires that on you
if it touches the ground you're supposed
to burn it believe it or not
and you can see this kind of reverence
on say military posts with the folding
the flag you can see this and how we use
flags for
service people
there's a lot of other aspects of civil
religion where
the state itself or important figures
are seen as
quasi-religious figures
abraham lincoln for example
when abraham lincoln was assassinated
now again it was a much more religious
nation at that time
he was portrayed as having given up his
his life for the nation as having taken
on the sins of slavery
and segregation
and being destroyed by the by the
southern slave holders who of course you
know that they were losing they lost the
war they were seen as you know
diabolical by by many people in the
north
and he was portrayed as being a kind of
christ figure
uh there's a lot of other instances of
this
saying the pledge of allegiance
is kind of a dividing line for a lot of
people isn't it
um when you know when i was a kid again
i grew up as a kid in the styx um
in the in the 70s and 80s
everybody just said the pledge of
allegiance at the beginning of the day
we didn't think anything of it
but that's sort of like you know um
catholics will go to mass every morning
and never think anything of it
or you know we can pick all sorts of
other examples like that
civil religion like your book points out
um
was very important in american religious
life but it's it's really gone on the
wane and it's become kind of a divisive
issue since the 60s and 70s
the 1960s and 70s way before your time
and even before my time
things radically changed in the way that
people viewed government
viewed the nation as a whole viewed
american culture yeah was that did that
have to do with um
with the pledge of allegiance because
wasn't it around them that they added
under god or something like that in the
1950s it was like 53 years yeah i think
um
yeah there was that was actually done in
part because of like the
we're going to stick it to the
communists and the way we'll stick it
like having this is we're going to all
be more religious because the communists
are against that
um and so there yeah there's debates
back and forth about could you should we
take in god out in god we trust was put
on currency around the same time
um
actually the the god we trust stuff on
currency would be civil religion too is
that what that's the divisions and that
time no the divisions are coming about
later
uh in the 60s and 70s and it's coming
about because of a loss of confidence in
in the government
the vietnam war had a massive effect on
this your book points out a lot of civil
religions actually tied in with
war imagery
you know the star-spangled banner
is this song about how we're beating the
the british
i think yeah the british you know the
rockets red blair you're not shooting
rockets like on the 4th of july just for
fun you're shooting rockets
because that's how you illuminate the
battlefield so you can shoot people
um
we we often lose a lot of this this sort
of stuff fourth of july was to
commemorate having beaten the british in
a war
you know
um
the vietnam war was a very traumatic
event
uh on all sorts of levels
and there was the secularization that
was going on at the time and and people
you know since then
um things like saying the pledge of
allegiance have become a very divisive
issue where people are very strongly on
this side very strongly on this side
some of us don't actually you know some
of us are practically agnostic with
respect to that
but that's that's civil religion
then your book like shifts totally and
starts talking about the
new age
and that kind of fits in with popular
religion as well
what do you guys think of when i say new
name
does anything come to mind
because it's really not that new
it's your grandparents that that really
got into it
that generation of baby boomers
my generation were you know some of them
got into it a lot of us are kind of like
skeptical
of that sort of stuff
i think your generation doesn't have
that much
connection with them
if somebody's a new agent person
what would they be into
there's a lot of that up in this area by
the way
and parked a lot of boomers moved out of
the city
bought land when it was cheap here in
the hudson valley
uh what what are new agers into what
sort of things
remember we talked about this a little
bit back when we're looking at
new thought back in the 19th century and
harmonious
movements like christian science and
spiritualism
mesmerism
that sort of thing
anything come to mind
like if you went into a new age
bookstore what do you think you know
besides books what do you think they'd
be selling
or is this totally foreign to your
experience
might be that there's that's that's a
possibility
uh education is always having to sort of
re-appropriate things for every new
generation
your generation's experience may be very
different
than
earlier generations experience
the new age was the age of aquarius
who do you associate that with
when you have any associations
okay hippies and who are these hippies
well we still use the word today right
which is not mainstream
lots about love peace and drugs
we even have like shows you know like
where that was
that became a thing like that 70s show
you know nostalgia
yeah the hippies were these these
counter cultural
people
never really well organized kind of all
over the map
a lot of them were pretty into drugs
especially psychedelic drugs and pot
they you know many of them protested the
vietnam war they were against war in
general
some made communes
you know
they wanted peace they wanted to you
know
undo the american system which was this
supposed to be this terrible bourgeois
killing field existence that was turning
everybody into conformists
um they're very disappointed by the way
in my generation and your generation for
not like carrying the torch
and
you know
keeping up
all this sort of stuff
um
nowadays we we tend to associate pots
working more with just recreational drug
use not so much with like raising your
consciousness
but there are some people you know
people who are into fish
follow them around wear hemp that are
kind of neo-hippies
um
the new age comes out of that time but
but there's there's different emphases
with this
um
like it points out there it's not a
very organized kind of movement
and a lot of the people who were
involved with it were
you know baby boomers that came of age
accustomed to suburban middle class
prerogatives if they call it of
education and security well at the same
time distanced from the social political
and religious institutions that helped
define their parents identities they
rebelled against their parents and this
is one way to rebel
um not such an option for for you guys
because the stakes are a lot higher
because it's harder to get jobs it's
hard you know you don't have the
security that your grandparents did
so central to the new age movement is
the idea of personal choice identity is
not described
descriptively by the social
circumstances it's elective it's what
you choose and so a lot of these people
are seekers and they go from one group
to another to another i'm going to try
this i'm going to try that
and
one of the concepts that they bring up
with this is self-realization this
notion that
you've got to find out who you really
are
you got to be the best you you can
possibly be
you have to um away all the stuff that's
holding you back
and they bring up two other other sort
of um
central concepts
healing
and holistic
when you hear people talking about
holistic right that term
um very often we're looking at new age
stuff
healing is is an important idea in it
and
like it says the new age movement
has this lineage it goes back to groups
like christian science and new thought
the premise is that the healing comes
through the correct realignment of the
person
with the spiritual forces that permeate
the universe are already potentially
imminent with us all so you know people
who are really into you know crystals
and attunements or aromatherapy the idea
is not just well it's pretty it looks
nice smells nice the idea is this is
actually supposed to sort of like
realign you
some people who do
massage therapy you know we'll give you
a little um
speech before they actually do the
massage and talk about you know breathe
in the healing force of the universe and
breathe out the bad whatever it is that
you've you know got just your stress
your
other things like that the view is that
you're actually by engaging in these
kind of practices
changing
the nature of your body mind spirit
to realign yourself with the cosmos
that's what the new age is really about
and this notion of holistic
when you say that something is holistic
what do you you know what do we mean by
that term
or is it lost all of its meaning
you guys associated with anything like
holistic medicine
does that mean anything to you guys yeah
of course
it's natural medicine
natural in what way because i mean
not synthetic chemicals like i said you
can ask when you go to a tree in canada
okay
yeah so going back to nature itself
is seen as more holistic than
opening up a bottle of bayer you know
taking salicylic acid
what you're getting from the tree is
salicylic acid if it's if it's aspirin
um
that's that's on the right track so
natural yeah oh yeah i'm gonna say
reconnecting with like
nature and the natural
um yeah materials and
nutrients now it's understanding nature
as a whole
that we're all part of like in an
ecosystem
and
so you want to approach things in a
holistic or taking everything into
account kind of
kind of man
so you know if you're doing holistic
medicine maybe in addition to i don't
say for arthritis right i suffer from
arthritis maybe some of you do too
in addition to like telling you well
don't sit down for a long time and stay
active
which is the last thing you want to do
and giving you some painkillers
maybe they do acupuncture
or you know
hydrotherapy
or maybe some massage there you try to
bring all these elements together you
know so keep on doing this movement
right that's a whole bringing everything
together
that's the notion of holistic that you
see in in new age the last thing that
they talk about is this notion of
channeling um and this was really
popular back in the 80s
and 90s it's kind of fallen there's less
talk about this now i think because a
lot of people make fun of it
um
but the idea was that uh you could you
could uh
give your body over to a kind of
possession by
my spirits who could speak through you
and your book points out this is really
a successor to the spiritualism
of the
1800s it's not a new phenomenon these
sort of things re-emerge over and over
again
um
your book talks also about cults
or
new religions
and if you if you call something occult
that doesn't sound good right
or does it
your friend joined a cult good thing or
bad thing that's bad why
what kind of definition you're using
well you're yeah that's that's an
important point
and your book says look in religious
studies it's a more neutral term it
means some sort of you know
systematic way of worshiping you know
but when in regular contemporary
discourse if your friend joined a cult
and you put that on facebook everyone's
going to say i'm so sorry for you how
can we get them out of the cult right
because we associate cults with bad
things if we use the more neutral term
new religions that can sometimes be
helpful
but what are the things that people do
associate with cults
let's say again
somebody puts on facebook
my brother just joined a cult
what would come to your mind
what kind of group are they who might
have paid money to get into it
okay yeah or like giving up their
property or something like that so
that's one aspect what else
yeah well the first one that possibly is
scientology
yeah and we're going to talk about about
scientology in just a minute but what
about in in general what or let's take
scientology what makes them cult-like
yeah like the first thing that would pop
in my head would be like um wildly
outlandish
thoughts and
teachings so it greatly had variance
with the majority views on things even
the majority views on things among
religious people
scientology is a great example too of
like costing a lot of money as well
so
some sort of you know
very distinctive beliefs
high barriers to joining once you're in
what's it like
yeah aren't you like isolated from like
everyone else besides like people
quite often these groups do tend to
say well you don't want to be associated
with the world
and it's you know there have been some
other groups that we've studied
up until this time think about the uh
the mennonites and the amish they you
know sort of segregate apart from
the rest of society
um
you could think about the uh
the mormons for whom you know the
ordinances are carried out of the temple
and not everybody gets to go to the
temple you know there's there's elements
like this in other things but yeah
you're right there tends to be a kind of
us versus them
uh and we do our stuff here
and uh
is it easy to leave once you're in all
these groups no
there's high barriers to to to leaving
so let's let's talk about scientology um
and we don't get much time let's talk
about it it's founded by this guy l ron
hubbard who um wrote a book called
dianetics and then wrote a lot of you
know other things as well much of which
are science fiction
and it's it's a non-theistic religion
and that you know it's not about
worshiping a gut but it combines
elements of depth theology with a belief
in reincarnation
uh its primary activity is called
auditing and they have these these
devices that are used for that
and
the the the goal is to become what they
call clear and then there's different
levels to it and it takes you know work
and often
um you know
going to seminars which costs a lot of
money to to reach these higher levels
what else do you associate with
scientology
that's sort of you know very very
thumbnail sketch
basis of it
celebrities
it has an inordinate number of
celebrities and even just
run-of-the-mill
uh hollywood people cameraman you know
producers
uh
casting directors associated with the
movement that part of that is probably
from being located
in in the area for a long time
um
there are particular celebrities that
people do associate with it as well tom
cruise for example
another thing that you know scientology
is very well known for is being
extremely litigious
and suing anybody who says anything bad
about the religion
uh and doing lawsuit after lawsuit
lawsuit um time magazine actually ran a
uh
sort of expose
on scientology years and years ago and
it was seen as a daring move at the time
because people who've done that were
what would you call it legally
persecuted
until that time
the unification church is another
group
which they they talk about in this
chapter
um
and they
have gotten a bit bit smaller
um they were again sort of a grow they
were a big concern back in the 70s and
80s
they were founded by this this uh
korean businessman sun moon
and
he like the book says he outlined a
reinterpretation of christianity which
incorporated some early christian
gnosticism
and some other elements
their view is in the beginning god
intended adam and eve would have to get
a perfect family
eve's seduction by lucifer ruined his
hope and
of divinely chosen figures we're
supposed to you know reinstate this
divine family thing jesus
was able to do that get ready for it
spiritually but wasn't able to fully
bring it off and
um
moon and and his wife are the modern day
ones that will do this
and they they um
they got a lot of controversy because of
these arranged marriages people would
join and it had all these elements of
you know that people associate with
cults of being hard to get into hard to
get out of
um you know radically at odds with a lot
of other organizations
and
once you're in one of the things that
they did was they would say all right
you are going to marry her
uh
now you know how they decided that
that's there's a whole you know story to
be told with that but um
you know you guys have been in a class
together would you guys uh like to get
married right now
either one of me
maybe somebody else that you know but
you know you don't really know each
other
that's what they were doing
and
um he got into trouble with not not so
much for that but on on other things and
ended up
going to
to prison
um your book talks a lot about other
occult scares
mentions the branch davidians
we might remember david korash it
mentions a much earlier group the the
jonestown
people's temple that you know fast
forward to
heaven's gate people and it's sort of
trying to figure out what do these all
have in common as it turns out they
really don't have a lot in common other
than
you know having those sort of
characteristics of cultish
behavior
there was a real scare
about cults
in the
80s and 90s you know people were afraid
like when i was a teenager that if we
were listening to the wrong kind of
music we might be joining a cult
probably a satanic cult and uh i'll
reverend a big special that got my my
sister's records put away for a while
and my mom
but a lot of it turned out to be
just sort of popular hysteria
and
that's really where where the uh
the story ends for this chapter it's
kind of ranged over a lot of stuff
is it all popular religion
not exactly not all in the same sense
but again this was that miscellaneous
drawer so he's kind of bringing things
to a close